the girag and experience he travels his
Roble I won't lie to you I've traveled a
great deal what were we talking about
right before the podcast started where
you have to bring this up on the pile
about so I did a podcast today with a
guy from crack comm Dan O'Brien wrote a
really funny book called how to fight
presidents to see who is the baddest ass
who's the one guy you wouldn't want to
fight and who would win in a fight if
they were pitted against each other it's
like it's in some ways the greatest book
of all time and like I said I go this is
this is gonna be the greatest podcast of
all time it was a funniest thing because
we got into a heavy heated argument
about who would win in a fight and you
got to put a couple presents up at the
top of the list you got to put Abe
Lincoln because he was renowned for his
physical strength there is fun he fought
vampires too right well he did if wait
but he isn't a movie you use an axe but
Abe Lincoln was 64 and had what that
that disease where your arms are longer
you have really long arms like longer
than your body if crazyland and he was
it was known to be really strong and and
very very tough hey boys I think you
also have to think of people that live
during that era there are a lot tougher
oh yeah they grew up doing everything
with their hands right building things
Andrew Jackson was a gentle sigh mean he
committed a little something called
genocide if you talk to historians
they're like well he killed a great deal
of Native Americans with extreme
prejudice so he that's not I wouldn't
that's a strong word what do you think
that Steve I don't think disease
transmission counts I agree is that what
he did he was a soldier and and did I
mean he was a he clearly probably killed
a lot of men with his bare hands that
with him I mean that was Behrens was
certainly with a gun or a knife I mean
he was a pretty warlike fella yeah and
in fact challenge he had a number of
duels historians are actually he got
shot and lived most of his life with a
bullet in his rib cage at shitty guns
back then
there's a debate how many duels he
actually had when you have when there's
a debate on how many duels you're
fucking president you're a bad
motherfucker or you're an idiot right
keep getting in tools well he got shot
cuz he let the guy take the first shot
he goes take the first shot guy shot him
then he shot the guy and lived that way
for the rest of his life he had he had a
gaping wound that would you know cause
problems periodically you take the first
shot Andrew Jackson of six - he was
drunk
George Washington six for who was a
tough guy George Washington was six for
he was people weren't that big dad no he
was a giant I'll tell you six for Jesus
Christ Washington was as big as this
motherfucker so much George Washington
could have beat my money on George's
wooden teeth it's got a fucking goofy
wig on pull that wig off that wig off
he's not gonna know what the fuck to do
he's gonna search for his wig he kicked
him in the dick next thing you know
you're pulling out his wooden teeth to
beat the shit out of him
then there was Lyndon Johnson who's also
64 but Teddy Roosevelt who practiced who
boxed wrestled and practiced judo with
the guy who brought judo to the United
States Lee of the first judo guy and was
obsessed with all things wrestling and
fighting he was about 510 and very thick
but a very sickly kid died of heart
disease had a weak heart so I don't know
my thing is Gerald Ford played football
and could have played for the Bears as a
middle linebacker that says a lot when
you play in the NFL so I might have to
go with we had a huge discussion about
this for a good hour I go with Bryan
Callen show and it was a good time I got
Lincoln so so then he said I said what
about Barack Obama and he got quiet
there Dan's a comedian really good guy
he got quiet and he said well I can't
really you know I I'd rather leave that
alone I said why I said well I try not
to you try not to include any living
presidents cuz it caused too much
trouble I said what do you mean he said
well I went through sort of a thing
about how you know Barack Obama's not
that tough for president and it'd be
easy to kick his ass and you know it was
doing it tongue-in-cheek you know you
probably kick him here and he's kind of
skinny and you could
and he gets a call from the Secret
Service because he posted it as a blog
he posted as a blog I'm from crack calm
well he said the reason the only blog
that's not up there anymore is that
because he got called down to the
federal building I believe I think
that's what he said it's on my podcast
and he had to go line by line with these
agents on what he meant by what he was
saying and he was like well I said you
know I said dick tornado instead of a
penis cyclone because it's kind of
funnier he was trying to teach them a
humor these guys were totally fucking
with us
he got all nervous he was like
apologizing he made they made him take
it down and it was a chapter that wasn't
money from the book of Lee so that I was
like we live in America how I mean now
you have to be careful when you've
threatened to present you will get cause
but guys guys come on come on man I mean
and heat I probably can't they probably
can't
well they said Robin no way to go like
yeah they probably knew of course he's
joking but there's a thing that there's
you set in motion a certain status what
happens because they said we will
subpoena everybody that made a comment
yeah on your on the blog his ass and and
and and Dan said well it's a bunch of
14-year olds have fun with that and what
the main guy that called him first he
goes look I know you're kidding I know
you got a sense of humor you gotta go
talk these guys it's just the way it is
pal
[Applause]